[Musique]
la crise sanitaire diego covit 19
impacte fortement notre territoire pour
faire face à l'état d'urgence sanitaire
social et économique
le département de la réunion se
mobilisent et engage un pacte de
solidarité sanitaire départemental
à travers ce pacte nous voulons aider
bien sûr les publics les plus fragiles
les publics avec lesquels nous
travaillons je pense aux personnes âgées
je pense aux personnes en situation de
handicap aux jeunes aux enfants
vulnérables et nous travaillons bien sûr
en lien avec un certain nombre de
partenaires qui sont les mairie et ccas
les associations les acteurs les
opérateurs de l'action sociale
territoriale et donc ce parc va
permettre déjà de répondre à ses
attentes
30 millions d'euros seront ainsi dégagé
pour venir en aide aux réunionnais comme
ce dispositif qui vise à renforcer les
interventions à domicile des aides
ménagères et à soutenir les services
d'aidé et d'accompagnement à domicile en
augmentant le nombre d'heures
d'aide-ménagère par mois on passe à 10
heures par mois possible en fonction du
qu'au cas par cas mais en tout cas c'est
une possibilité qui est offerte pour
justement accompagner au mieux nos
personnes âgées ou personnes handicapées
par exemple les faire leurs courses à
leur place par exemple aujourd'hui nous
sommes dans une mesure de confinement
les personnes âgées ont peur de sortir
et bien la laine ménagères à sur les
courses pour la personne âgée
le département va également augmenter le
nombre de portage de repas à domicile
afin de toucher le plus grand nombre de
personnes en situation d'isolement la
collectivité soutiendra la filière
agricole en proposant la livraison de
paniers de fruits et légumes frais aux
bénéficiaires les plus vulnérables et
dort le département va pouvoir acquérir
poids 12000 paniers de fruits et légumes
chaque semaine donc près de 50000 par
mois pour pouvoir aider à l'écoulement
de la production agricole et ses
produits iront vers les familles en
grande nécessité en passant comme je le
dis par les ccas et par les opérateurs
les assistants familiaux les foyers de
l'enfance et les jeunes créateurs
d'entreprises seront également soutenus
par le département un pacte de
solidarité sanitaire départemental qui
s'étendra sur les trois prochains mois
[Musique]